life isn't possible in space
the simple phrase traced on the opening
screen encompasses the very poignant
manner in which the movie gravity is
able to offer us a perfectly coherent
and symbolically rich death and
resurrection story within the science
fiction frame
[Music]
this is Jonathan Petro
welcome to the symbolic world
[Music]
[Applause]
in ancient cosmology the margin of the
world the great ocean which surrounds it
were images of wonder promise and
surprise but also adversity foreign
enemies death and ultimately chaos the
shape of the world has not changed in
its essential elements all that used to
be contained in those outer rims of the
world has now been projected out into
outer space there we encounter infinite
wonder gigantic scale infinite alien
monsters and the breakdown of our usual
systems of reference in gravity the
ancient cosmic symbols of the edge of
the world are all lined up in outer
space all joined to the personal journey
of a woman to accept to face and
overcome the tragic and absurd death of
her daughter we can see all the elements
of gravity as a web of consequences
laying themselves out due to the
movement away from a center the spinning
the dizziness and fragmentation which
occurs with a general loss of meaning in
the first secrets of the movie the sense
of normal is already exploded as a ship
appears above the earth floating upside
down but technology the ship itself like
an arc in the void but also the
spacesuits as protective garments are
the sign that order is contained in this
state of exile the crews constant
communication with home you know is the
necessary act of memory which is crucial
in order to stay connected to who we are
to our identity to our purpose when we
are far away from our origins in both
time and space
the shape of memory and connection is
stored the experience of outer space is
one of wonder for Kowalski for whom it
is his last mission but it is one of an
easy awkwardness for dr. Ryan stone for
whom it is actually her first mission
and this relationship of the transition
between the end and the beginning will
be a constant theme in the story the
protective garment and the connection to
home is put in danger by an event which
signifies this breakdown of order a
missile strike by the Russians on their
own satellite causes a series of
accidental collisions with other
satellites which fragment into this
chaotic spray of debris the residues of
technology which have now become a
danger to their purpose to their mission
in this event we both get the action of
a foreign alien the a foreign agent as
well as the accidental itself both of
these signify a confrontation with the
unknown and with a collapse of meaning
communication with home of course is
also cut off the general breakdown is
shown here and in all the other
instances in the movie where these
chaotic residues circle back it's shown
as an amazing and dizzying fragmentation
things spin and collide and both
extremes manifest themselves
simultaneously that is both the danger
of being detached from anything stable
right lost to the emptiness of the void
as well as the danger of remaining
attached to a collapsing structure
damages to
Laure are catastrophic the ship is
destroyed and in the remaining debris
and death we see the first of three
totems or mascots Marvin Martian who is
the ultimate caricature of an alien
wanting to destroy earth and manifest
this intrusion of chaos and destruction
while skiing the story acts as the wise
man of experience the guiding force
which teaches Ryan what to do and guides
her along her path
he literally tethers Ryan to himself and
guides her both psychologically and
physically through the void from which
he has actually caught her in that sense
he acts as a father figure as she
navigates through the chaos the solution
to their problem you know with her ship
destroyed is to embark on a journey and
travel across the void in many ways it's
shown as an impossible void which goes
west and east at the same time going
west in space towards the place where
the Sun sets but also strangely going
east as they move towards the Russian
run Space Station and then finally
attained the Chinese station in order
that they can finally return to Earth as
they travel kawalsky continues to
express his wonder and he attempts to
coax Ryan out of her story beautiful
don't you think
what the sunrise and in her telling
that's where we discovered that the
story her story is not finished that
after her experience of tragedy she is
left driving around without a purpose
this is an echo of her spinning and
floating aimlessly in outer space in the
approach of the space station kawalsky
ends up sacrificing himself to save
rhine and then he guides her towards her
purpose ending his life with a story in
wonder and with music you should see the
Sun on the Ganges
[Music]
it's amazing
if Ryan succeeds Kowalski tells her she
will find her story from that point the
pattern of this relationship between
death and rebirth and in beginning
repeat themselves over and over to show
us the different aspects of transition
between the two Ryan is still moving
away from meaning this move away appears
as moving into foreign space first in
the Russian station chance to look at
the instruction manual to figure out you
know the Russian controls and then she
finds herself randomly guessing which
button to push once she's in the Chinese
station if in the American ship she saw
Marvin Martian here in the Russian ship
she finds an icon of Saint Christopher
who is the patron saint of travelers but
who was also a converted enemy an alien
in his own matter known as one of the
monstrous races of the ancient world a
giant or else a dog headed man st.
Christopher is shown carrying Christ
across the waters in this moment when
Ryan finds herself in the Russian escape
pod she actually recapitulates the story
of Saint Christopher almost perfectly
she encounters the breakdown of meaning
through a man who's speaking to her in a
foreign tongue that she cannot
understand this breakdown of meaning
reaches its limit as it descends into
The Barking of dogs which she herself
imitates
this tumble into an animal existence
into animality is a common image of
death and chaos in traditional stories
but within the barking of dogs appears
the voice of a child and so just like
the dog headed Christopher carries the
child across so - she encounters her own
hope of rebirth but she still needs to
cross the waters of death and so she
descends into the underworld where she
encounters the ghost of kawalsky like
the Roman hero Aeneas visiting his
father and Kowalski gives her the piece
of the puzzle she needs the change of
death back into life appears as a final
trick a final inversion like Christ
descending into death and tricking Hades
into taking light into darkness like in
the legend of Saint Christopher where
Christ's tricks and Christopher st.
Christopher was looking to serve the
most empower 'fl Being and now he finds
himself carrying an innocent child so -
the solution to Ryan's death is a
surprise inversion that is to use the
landing mechanism to take off
having reached the Chinese station Ryan
encounters an image of the Chinese
Buddha the last mascot Buddha is of
course also a for an image to her but it
is an image of prosperity and cheer in
Chinese Buddhism Buddha is understood as
a manifestation of Maitreya that is the
last and final Buddha and so from the
hostile Martian to the transitional st.
Christopher we now see the future open
once more although I've already said
she's still in chaos
she must guess which button to push but
she moves no longer in despair and
discouragement but she moves with
excitement and exploration in the
unknown and it is this excitement that
we discover in Ryan as she goes through
a purging fire we find there both her
renewed spark for life as well as her
acceptance of a possible end
what's enlivening her is how she has
finally found her story she has found
her sense of wonder and she's willing to
go through hell to living
it'll be one hell of a right
communication is recovered with home and
they asked her to confirm her identity
but there is one more cycle of death and
rebirth we need to see the cold dark
void of outer space has to be directly
connected to the chaos and death of the
deep of baptism like Saint Christopher
she pledges into the void of the lake
until now she toiled to protect herself
with garments and Technology but now she
must in the end remove her layers to
regain the earth regain her ground with
a grateful prayer she encounters the
balance of heaven and earth experiences
up and down regains her Center meaning
just as she has regained her story and
it is in that moment that she finally
resurrects but she can stand again in
joy and wonder though with pain and
stumbling and move forward
you
okay everybody I hope you enjoyed my
interpretation of gravity there are a
lot of things happening these days next
month I'm going to be in Seattle and I'm
going to have a few speaking events in
the next few months I will probably be
in Florida speaking as well and possibly
in South Carolina there'll be some
speaking events as well I'm gonna put
all those on my website as soon as
possible and you can go find those dates
if you want my carving workshop for this
September is totally full so if you were
interested in that you'll have to sign
up for next year for all of those that
are supporting me on patreon I want to
give you a little bit of a hint of you
know the help that you are providing
what it's doing you know about let's say
almost 10 years ago my brother met here
and I we wrote a screenplay and it's
very relevant to this interpretation of
gravity because the screenplay was a
kind of epic retelling of the story of
st. Christopher it was kind of like Lord
of the Rings but set in byzantine early
Byzantine area with there was Saint
Christopher and st. George there were
Giants and Dragons and pretty much every
single character in Genesis it was a
very epic thing and we wrote it being a
bit naive about how Hollywood works and
how these movies are made we did have it
scouted and we had some interest from
some Studios who requested the script
but obviously such a such a let's say
original and very expensive movie was
not going to be made in the past several
years I've just been kind of struggling
to survive as an icon Carver and Matt
Jared was writing his book and so that
project was just on the shelf and just
gathering dust but now with all of your
patreon support I've been able to free
part of my mind and have jumped back
into that project and so Matt's you and
I are having the screenplay developed as
a graphic novel we have an artist his
name is Courtney listen and he has
already started working on character
design and he's already you know
penciled the first sections and working
on thumbnailing the whole thing so so
just you know just to tell you
you know how how much has been able to
free up my mind and hopefully very soon
we'll have a pretty crazy story to offer
you guys will probably have a
Kickstarter or some other kind of a
crowdfunding project to to raise some
money to be able to finish the art of it
and also to be able to publish it so
look forward for that and as usual
thanks for your support
and I'll see you soon if you enjoyed
this content and our exploration of
symbolism get involved I love to read
your insights and questions in the
comments section you can also share this
video on social media to your friends
and as you can please consider
supporting us financially through
patreon or PayPal you'll find those
links in the description below